i came back
in my home of rwanda two years
after the 1994 genocide against the
tutsi
the country was devastated the children
i was carrying off at the hospitals were
dying for treatable
conditions because we didn't have
equipment
or medicines to save them
i was tempted to pack my bag
and run away but i debate with myself
and because i'm really dedicated to
social justice
and equity and there were there were
only five pediatricians in total for
millions
of children in rwanda
i decided to stay but among the people
who have motivated my decision to stay
there was some fantastic woman of rwanda
some women who had
faced the genocide and survived it
they had to overcome unbelievable
pain and suffering some of them were
raising children conceived
through rape others were dying
slowly with hiv and forgive the
perpetrators who voluntarily
infected them using hiv and rape as a
weapons
so they inspired me if they can do that
i can stay and try to do my best
those ladies were really activists
of peace and reconciliation they show
us a way to rebuild a country for our
children
and grandchildren to have one day a
place they can call
home with pride
and you can ask yourself
where this shift of mindset has brought
our country today in rwanda
we have the highest percentage
of women in parliament
with that i tell you the the percentage
61 percent
today we have the best campaign
for vaccination of children with among
our success
93 of our girls vaccinated against hpv
to prevent them against cervical cancer
in this country is 54.
we have reduced child mortality by 75
percent
maternal mortality by 80 percent
in early 2000 there were nine women
who were dying every day around delivery
and pregnancy today is around two
it's an unfinished agenda we still have
a long way to
go two it's still too much
but do we do i believe
that those results are due because we
had
a big number of women in power position
i do there
is yes there is a study
in the developing world who show that
if you improve the status of women you
improve
the status of the community where they
live
up to 47 percent of decrease
in child mortality and even in this
country where we are now
it's true there is a study of ladies
called
patricia allman who
project that if women and men were at
parity
in state legislatures there will be
a drop of 14.5 percent
in child mortality in america
so we know that
women when they use their skills in
leadership position
they enhance the entire population they
are in charge for
and imagine what would happen
if women were at parity with men
all over the world what a huge benefit
we could expect
oh yeah because
in general we have different style of
leadership
more inclusive more empathetic
more caring for little children
and this make the difference
unfortunately that this ideal doesn't
exist
in the world and the difference between
men and women in leadership position
is too big gender
inequity is the norm in the majority of
profession
even in global health
i have learned that if we focus
on women education
we improve their life positively
as well as the well-being of the
community
this is why now i dedicate my life
to education and this is totally aligned
with
my sense of equity and my
pursuit of social justice because
if you want to increase access to
health services you need first to
increase
access to health education so
with friends and partners we are
building a beautiful university
in the rural north of rwanda we educate
our students
to provide quality
equitable holistic care to everyone
leaving no one out focusing on the
vulnerable especially
women and children who are historically
the last to be served
we transform them in leaders and give
them
managerial skills and advocacy skills
for them to be smooth change makers
in the society where they will be so
that they can
build health system will allow them to
care about the vulnerable
way they are and it's really
transformative
because currently
medical education for example is giving
an institution based in cities
focus on quality health services
and skills clinical skills
to be given in institutions
we also focus on quality
clinical skills but with
biosocial approach to the condition of
patient
for care to be given in communities
where the people live with
hospitalization
only when necessary
and also after four to seven years
clinical education in cities
young graduates doesn't want to go back
to rural area
so this is why we have built
the university of global health equity
an initiative of partnering health
called ugg
in the rural north of rwanda
our students are meant
to go and change the world
they will come from all over it's a
global university
and will get the medical education for
free
at one condition they have to serve the
vulnerable across the world
during six to nine years they will keep
their salary
for themselves and their families but
turn the education we give
in quality clinical services especially
for the vulnerable
and doing so
they sign an agreement at start
that they will do that a binding
agreement
we don't want money we have to go and
mobilize the money
but they will turn this in quality
service delivery for all
for this of course we need a strong
gender equity agenda and in
all our classes master's course minimum
of 50 percent of
women
and i'm proud to say that for the
medical school
who started five months ago we have
enrolled 70 percent of girls
[Applause]
this is a statement against the current
inequity for women to access medical
education
in our continent
i believe in
women education this is why i applaud
african ladies who go all over the world
to
increase the education the skills and
the knowledge
but i hope they will bring that back to
africa
to build the continent and make
the continent a strong continent because
i'm sure
a stronger africa will make the world
stronger
and
23 years ago i went back
in rwanda in a broken rwanda
that's now is still a poor country but
shining
with a bright future and i'm full of joy
to have come back even if some day were
very difficult
and even if someday i was depressed
because i didn't find the solution and
people were dying or things were not
moving
enough but i'm so proud
to have contributed to improve my
community
and this make me full of joy
so african woman from the diaspora
if you hear me never forgot
your homeland and when you are ready
come back home
i did so it has
fulfilled my life so
come back home thank you